they make billions of dollars smuggling
drugs and illicit Goods across the
border into the United States and many
of their leaders are wanted across the
border but who are the powerful Mexican
drug cartels
the Mexican cartels are the bigger
suppliers of illegal drugs into the
United States they move heroin and
cocaine methamphetamine or crystal meth
are now fentanyl in Tijuana alone there
are three cartels fighting for power the
Sinaloa cartel Jalisco new generation
and the Tijuana cartel
although there are many other cartels in
Mexico these three plus another known as
the golf cartel are the most powerful in
the country
the golf cartel is the oldest cartel in
Mexico Jalisco New Generation come from
Jalisco State and they deal mainly in
cocaine now the Tijuana cartel
traditionally ran the drugs business in
the city but the Sinaloa cartel has
moved into their Turf and taken away
some of the business it means now that
the city is at the center of a major and
bloody Turf War making it one of the
most dangerous cities in the country it
is also worth remembering however that
cartels are more like a Cooperative
different factions and different
families all operating under one name
[Music]
the United States is the biggest
consumer of both legal and illegal drugs
in the world and a border between
Tijuana and San Diego is one of the
busiest Crossing points it's been at the
center of trafficking for decades and
it's not just drugs but it's human
smuggling as well
arguably the most powerful family and
certainly the most talked about family
in the Sinaloa cartel is the Guzman
family and its notorious leader El Chapo
now El Chapo is currently in prison
serving a life sentence in the United
States but the family business goes on
and Fentanyl is right at its heart
or traditionally the Mexican drug trade
depended upon plant-based products like
heroin and cocaine but the Sinaloa
cartel itself says that's very much part
of the history of the drug business now
they no longer need to have huge swathes
of land or have Farmers worrying about
variable weather conditions they've now
moved on to chemical based drugs
synthetic drugs as they are known and
they're much more lucrative and far
easier to make
cocaine production is still big business
here but fentanyl is catching up quickly
and the reason it's quite simple it's
much easier to produce and it's more
lucrative because you can ship less and
make more money as far as the cartels
are concerned synthetic drugs are the
future